uh joining us now is senator tom cotton
who serves on the senate armed services
committee an intelligence committee uh
excuse me senator you just heard peter
ducey um uh this report that lloyd
austin told senators during this
briefing
that the administration is now looking
at ways
to train ukrainian forces remotely
i don't need to be laugh at this but
what's your reaction to that
well it's just one more example of how
the bible administration is on the back
foot and has ceded the initiative to
vladimir putin even more disappointing
of what we heard in that phone call is
that president biden has ceded the veto
pin to our european allies on the kind
of sanctions we impose you mentioned
kicking
russia out of the international banking
system known as swift
apparently there's some european nations
like germany that don't want to do that
so we're not going to kick them out of
swift likewise oil and gas are russia's
two largest exports europe is in many
cases beholden to russian oil and gas
moreover joe biden's
reckless energy policies have already
driven up the price of oil and gas over
the last year so even he and his
administration is admitting they don't
want to impose oil and gas sanctions on
russia because they're afraid it's going
to add to the inflation they've already
created well how about we impose those
sanctions but we lift all those
restrictions on the production of
american oil and gas so we can start
drilling on federal lands again and
putting out new leases so we can reopen
the keystone pipeline which would bring
more oil into america every day from
canada than we import every day from
russia that's what we should be doing
yeah well senator cotton to your point
on isn't this the moment where you show
some flexibility even if you're a
climate change fanatic
show some flexibility and concern for
your fellow americans on this but john
kerry
frankly continues to embarrass himself
in this country and the world stage with
his comments today about what to do next
massive
uh emissions consequences to the war but
equally importantly you're going to lose
people's focus you're going to lose
certainly big country attention because
they will be diverted and and i think it
could have a damaging impact so i hope
president putin will help us to stay on
track with respect to what we need to do
for the climate
now senator what are the chances and
one to ten ten being the most likely
that vladimir putin is up tonight
worrying about really meeting john
kerry's climate goals
[Music]
it's a number somewhere below zero
somewhere below zero laura that those
are the rantings of a deluded ideologue
most americans are not ideological about
these matters they're clear-eyed they're
sober and they understand that you
should not disarm your own energy
production when a brutal dictator uses
energy as a weapon against our partners
and then invades an innocent nation and
creates some of those scenes that you
played earlier of children screaming and
family scrambling into subway stations
most americans understand it's basic
common sense that we want to be able to
protect our own energy supply and
hopefully supply europe the energy it
needs to get off of russian energy
well i want to talk a little bit about
the idea that i grew up understanding
when i worked for president reagan of
peace through strength
a weakened america senator cotton what
does that tell the rest of the world our
southern border is wide open we don't
have the media coverage of that and all
that carnage the results southern border
except on fox southern border our
economy inflation high energy prices and
uh all the rest of the nonsense with the
coveted mandates and everything i mean
what does that tell the rest of the
world
and what did it tell putin and xi well
it well it's told vladimir putin over
the last six months that he can build up
200 000 troops on ukraine's border and
invade and if we don't bring the hammer
down on vladimir putin if we don't turn
russia into a pariah state and isolate
them diplomatically and economically and
financially it's going to tell xi
jinping he can probably do the same
thing in taiwan after all he's on the
other side of the world taiwan doesn't
have the same kind of ties to europe
that ukraine does his economy is 10
times size larger than russia's
it's simply creating permission around
the world for our adversaries to try to
press our against our interests try to
undercut our partners and our allies
and ultimately put our own safety and
freedom and prosperity at risk
senator good to see you tonight thank
you so much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else